okay
i'm maury samuels the director of the
yale program for the study of
anti-semitism
and it's my great pleasure to welcome
you here to to today's webinar
part of our benjamin and barbara zucker
lecture
series our speaker is well known to many
of us
jason stanley is the jacob your wife
your wife
yorowski professor of philosophy at yale
before coming to yale in 2013 he was
distinguished professor in the
department of philosophy
at rutgers a philosopher of language and
epistemology
as well as a social and political
philosopher he's the author of numerous
books
including knowledge and practical
interests 2005
language in context 2007
know-how 2011 and two more recent books
that touch on aspects of our current
political
situation how propaganda works 2015
and how fascism works the politics of us
and them 2018 and this last one
especially has made him
kind of a media star lately i should say
that
my colleague alice kaplan also asked me
to
point out that jason along with tim
snyder will be giving a frankie seminar
at the whitney humanities center next
year
on mass incarceration in the soviet
union and the united states
with side long looks at nazi germany and
china
so please check the whitney humanities
center website for more information on
that
finally before we get started just a
word on how things today
will work jason will talk for about 30
minutes
uh and then we'll open it up for
questions the audience is
not visible or audible so please submit
your questions
using the q a button at the bottom of
your screen
and i will ask the questions feel free
to submit
questions whenever you want even during
the talk um that would actually be
helpful to me if they came in
early please don't raise your hand or
use the chat functions because they
um they i we won't see them uh so the
title
of professor stanley's talk today is
anti-semitism and white supremacy
please join me in welcoming jason
stanley
thank you so much uh so uh
and thank you for for coming uh so
uh i want to talk uh today
about uh something that's about
growing anti-semitism in the united
states
uh and the structure and how it relates
to what's going on in the world today
and our and
our own very particular political
situation
uh our own particular in particular our
history
of white supremacy so let's begin with
what's going on uh i'm going to begin
with
uh the national situation the
international situation
uh and uh with one aspect of the
international situation
and then i'm going to talk a little bit
about whites about what we face with
white supremacy in the united states
against
uh black americans and then i'm going to
connect
this uh to the topic of today
anti-semitism
so as my colleague ali stern has been uh
my colleague ali stern has been drawing
our attention
to a global move in many countries not
yet in the united states
of jewish voters to right-wing
anti-often
anti-immigrant parties uh somewhat even
xenophobic parties
uh which uh movement uh that you see
in in europe and certainly
there is of course a far right in israel
this belies a long history of jewish
voters
jewish participation since emancipation
on uh being uh on the side of
uh ethnic religious minorities uh that
were not
uh themselves so uh so
but you we don't have this movement
anything that we have uh
it's sort of divided here so we have a
lot of orthodox voters supporting
far-right parties uh far-right movements
but
uh but it's less of um but we still have
uh a majority sort of liberal
progressive uh
voting uh constituency um now let's
turn so there is this move across the
world
towards a kind of um that seems like a
repudiation
of a long history of recognizing a
common alliance
between um between uh
jewish fate uh in a country and
uh the fate of other minority groups um
partly um there is a country that is a
jewish
uh that that is uh israel
israel exists now and so that gives uh a
sort of not there's a nationalist
movement
uh there's a there's a there's a nation
that is associated with
the religion but but uh
whatever the explanations of that my
topic here is the united states
is focused on what's going on in the
united states
let me quick and so i'm going to quickly
review some basic
facts um and then i'm going to
uh i'm going to talk about what
anti-semitism
what uh what one structure of
anti-semitism
looks like that's shared between uh
the protocols of the elders of zion and
say henry ford's the international jew
and the ku klux klan and how that links
jewish americans uh to uh
to our uh black fellow citizens whether
jewish or not
or not um and and what's happening
and then i'm gonna conclude by looking
at
the anti the talking about q anon
talking about the kind of growing
anti-semitism that we're finding
particularly
uh in in in in uh in the republican
party among certain members of the
republican party
uh the kind of uh we already see it with
uh
open george soros uh uh vilification
uh so uh so uh when victor orban
uh uh ran a political campaign
against uh condemning george soros
against george soros and hungary
it was clearly recognized as
anti-semitic
now giuliani and and many other
republicans can
condemn george soros openly is behind
every bad thing and and link him
in exactly the ways that anti-semitic
conspiracy theories link jews to
uh to minority groups uh and no one
seems to bat an
eye uh and i'm going to argue this is an
extraordinarily dangerous development
for uh for the safety and security of uh
of american jews uh sorry
i'm trying to ah here we go uh so um
so let me begin so what's going on
what let's just review some history in
the united states
so when i last so we all know that this
country
uh is based it has a long history of
explicit enslavement of its black
population
and then uh we we in in
many senses were not a democracy until
the voting rights act until black
americans in the south were able to vote
and we're seeing
this uh we're seeing this rise again
with voter disenfranchisement focusing
on
black majority cities uh trump uh
trump uh declared the voter fraud to be
focused in detroit
atlanta philadelphia milwaukee this was
no accident
these are either black majority cities
or cities with large black
populations so uh he was hearkening back
to
a long standing uh practice in the
united states
that black in the black radical
tradition was always linked
with uh with fascism uh tony morrison
in a 1995 speech at howard university
um talks of called racism and fascism
uh points says that uh she she says the
united states she's not talking she
doesn't say the united states is a
fascist regime
she says that the united states has
often preferred
fascist solutions to its national
problems
and what and what are the fascist
solutions she said taking
the minority population and
incarcerating them
in large numbers now
uh if we look at uh so these parallels
between
uh between uh european fascism
and uh and say the jim crow south have
been explored in detail by my yale
colleague
jim whitman and in his book hitler's
american model
the nuremberg laws were of course
modeled on our anti-miscegenation laws
and uh i just recently found out uh when
umass digitalized dubois archives that
w b du bois had a piece rejected from
the atlantic in 1942
uh where he made a direct analogy
between
hitler's treatment of jews and the
south's treatment of black americans
so uh so the tradition of of the
mainstream press
repudiating these analogies is also old
so uh so when i in 2014
with my con then colleague vesla weaver
i looked at
the numbers of for mass incarceration in
the united states
um as as you may know the united states
leads the world in the rate at which it
incarcerates
its fellow citizens um so uh
uh so so
so looking at these numbers what we
found was if you just looked at
the black population in prison
uh i think we have 38 million black
americans
uh those 30 uh uh
the they're incarcerated at such a high
rate
that in 2014 they formed almost 10
of the uh of the world's prison
population
whenever i say that people say there
must be some misunderstanding
uh there must be some uh misstatement
but it's not a misstatement uh in 2014
black americans a tiny tiny group
uh formed almost 10 percent of the
world's prison population
so when we talk about racism and white
supremacy this is not some kind of past
problem it's not a problem locatable
to uh to uh to lack of diversity
among faculty although it is also
present there
uh or in professions um
almost 10 of the world's prison
population comes from
uh the uh from the 38 million population
of 38 million black americans if germany
had had a substantial population of
german jews and was incarcerating them
at rates like we see in the united
states
uh the world would never stand for it
so obviously there is an enormous
unresolved
and continuing problem of racism in the
united states
uh that's linked that's multifactorial
linked to
many issues um but uh
the facts are the facts so uh
so so what uh what does this have
have to do with uh with anti-semitism
well i want now to move to what may seem
like a different topic
i'm gonna sit down again because um
as they tell me on on interviews i'm
sometimes
i sometimes look like i'm dobbing uh but
uh
where i'm standing up but uh so
so uh let's go back to the structure of
the anti-semitic conspiracy
theory the protocols of the elders of
zion
um so the protocols of the elders of
zion
says that jewish that jew that there's a
global conspiracy
of jews of elite jews
who are seeking to advance social
justice movements
to break apart nations to to to
uh so the idea so that uh in in the
words of
uh in protocol says that uh
movements for universal social justice
universal rights
rights for minority groups rights for
women
always have this global this
unholy alliance of capitalist jews and
communist jews behind them
so the idea is that uh that
uh the idea the central idea of the uh
the protocols of the elders design is
that liberalism um
[Music]
moves for social justice for minority
groups religious
uh uh uh uh
gender equality uh gay rights
uh that these always have behind them uh
this conspiracy of jews
uh and the goal is to destroy the
nation's
nation-states and replace it with world
government
now if you look at the ideology of the
second clan
in the 1920s in the united states um
you will find a remarkably similar story
this has been explored in nancy mclean's
1994 book she has a chapter on the
overlaps between
the ideology of the clan in the 1920s
and the uh and growing nazi ideology
and sarah churchwell has also explored
this in her
uh in her work on interwar fascism in
the united states
uh indeed many uh newspapers as sarah
churchwell notes
uh thought of the italian fact
the italian fascists were described as a
kind of italian ku klux klan
so clan ideology had it that uh that
this that jews were behind
uh movements for black equality and were
behind the labor movement
and the labor movement was a uh a method
of uh of destroying capitalism
and br and forcing uh black americans
and white americans to work side beat
by side as brothers and sisters and the
idea was
that jews were bringing rape were trying
to foam and then the basic thought is
jews are trying to foment racial
division
so they could take over so the clan
ideology is very similar to the
protocols of the elders of zion and you
find
and it's no surprise of course that
henry ford
uh distributed the international jew
hundreds of thousands of copies
which has a similar ideology
now what i'm going to do is i'm going to
show you a video
that was uh that uh i'm gonna show you
stills from a video
that was uh shown right after rudy
giuliani's
uh speech at the january sixth rally
stop the steel rally in washington dc
uh and now that you have this
understanding
that jews the global jews
the global elite are there trying to
and their goal is to undermine white
christianity
by creating racial divisions
and undermining uh and undermining
society so they can take over
i want you to think about that as we
look at some of these stills
so this was directly after giuliani's
speech
and soon before trump's speech that
culminated the rally when people
marched to the u.s capitol and as i
spend a lot of time on far-right
websites
there is a division between the far
right about what to think about
jews uh you know of there's one group
that's like separate but equal israel's
fine
you know but another group says no you
know
they're always bad so um but this is the
kind of thing you see and it's becoming
increasingly
mainstream so i'm going to share my
screen now
um i'm gonna uh so here's how the video
begins so this was shown
officially at a at this rally that right
after giuliani's speech
uh that trump speaks out and then right
after this they go
over to the capitol uh to uh
engage in the the events that
uh we're now seeing discussed
um in the impeachment trial so this is
the beginning of the video this is the
first film
and they show the capitol building the
target
then they move to a high to a hollywood
to just to a
hollywood sign now
uh in chapter two of mineconf and i'm
not making an analogy between trump and
hitler i think such analogies
analogies are foolish i am saying that
there's a similar
rhetoric and propaganda happening uh
so uh hitler in chapter two of mein
kampf uh which is about
his study and struggles in vienna uh he
says that he's
his first he claims his first
quote-unquote realist supposed
realization
that jews were in charge were sort of
nefariously in charge of things
was his supposed realization that they
controlled
the theater uh the theater uh and arts
so this is a long you know when you hear
hollywood is controlled by jews
that's a long that some aspect of that
is very long-standing
in anti-semitic thought and anti-semitic
ideology and conspiracy theories
also that the media is controlled by the
leftist global elite
note that when you think about that
claim that the media is controlled by
the leftist global elite
think about the fact that fox news has
long been the number one
station that sinclair broadcasting which
is a far right
station uh controls more local
television
networks than i believe any of anyone
else any
other media conglomerate so it's as
jeffrey herf has documented in detail uh
in the case of nazi germany
the claim is completely with the jews
the claim is completely false that
the left controls uh much less
jewish left or jewish right um
so here we find a hollywood we see a
hollywood uh
sign so this is really an official
rally uh uh beginning it begins with
hollywood then we look at
the un general assembly uh
i thank just security for helping me
distill these frames
the website justin hendricks helped me
um
so uh this is uh the un general assembly
so the idea of a global cabal
globe world government which according
to the international jew
according to the ku klux klan according
to the protocols of the elders of zion
is controlled by jews now we see the
european union parliament floor
uh so another global institution that
destroys
the individuality of nations
trump then then we oh the these the
uh then we see for too long a small
group in our nation's capitals reap
rewards of
government while the people have borne
the costs so this idea this small
group in our nation's capital now one
thing
hitler says in mein kampf is he notes he
says the second thing after the
entertainment industry
that he noticed he noticed that there
were prominent members of the austrian
social democratic party
who were jews and these seem to be
prominent members who had sort of a
controlling role
so he notes first jewish control of
the entertainment industry and secondly
he he notes
prominent members jewish members the
austrian social democratic party
the next still is biden
president biden with a vacant stare in
his eyes
and then we shift to chuck schumer
senator chuck schumer wearing a kente
cloth
now what's going on with senator chuck
schumer wearing a kente cloth
well remember recall that according to
ku klux klan
ideology jews foment racial division
so they can ultimately take over
why choose specifically chuck schumer
with the
kente cloth so we have joe biden
being so he's not in control
then we see chuck schumer and he's
wearing a kente cloth because
this is a reference to the aspect of of
this anti-semitic ideology that jews are
fomenting racial division
so part of this ideology you repeatedly
have the ku klux even members of the ku
klux klan saying
you know black people are okay as long
as they're in their place they're good
good black people the idea is jews are
are
stirring them up so uh then we see
uh nancy pelosi flanked by adam schiff
and jerry nadler to
jewish congresspersons um and this
seems uh to suggest that she's
controlled by those congress people
so the idea here is that um
that uh that the uh
that jewish prominent jewish members
of the democratic party uh have a kind
of controlling
role um uh so uh
i i've a number of people have said to
me that oh
why i think this was so carefully done
maybe this was just so slapped together
um it's far too deliberate to be slapped
together so
one thing you see in the video is uh let
me know
just a couple you see under trump like
this is of
the scenes of the glorious trump years
they're all scenes of his rallies
you see racial unity so racial unity
under trump so trump brings racial unity
uh schumer divides we're gonna see more
black lives matter protests uh so this
is the kind of imagery from
from that's trump behind us um so i want
to show you
later so if you look at if you think
that this is not carefully done so these
are
these are this is a part in the video uh
this you have these glorious trump years
look at this this is trump just with
with
everyone else faded out but him then you
have these glorious trump years if you
think this is not
carefully done then the suggestion that
covet is a democratic plot
if you look at this subway station the
subway station's called clinton
so this is very carefully put together
uh so uh i'm gonna show one last
science scene from this uh so here we
have
you know the racial division supposed
racial division black lives matter
um and uh and then let me show you
something else another sign of racial
unity here is like the end
it ends with this is what happens if
trump is restored we have a black man
and a white man uh uh
uh uh unified under jesus saves
under christian nationalism which is
increasingly
an ideology that a growing ideology in
the united states
that is a threat to me and all of us who
are
jewish americans uh and uh you know the
idea that america is first and foremost
a christian nation
um you know uh obviously there's strong
support for
not obviously with their strong support
for israel in very evangelical circles
that believe that
america is a christian nation uh think
of it as separate but equal
you know and we know separate but equal
that is not you know uh for we american
jews
that's not something that we should
really promote
um so i've been i i speak a lot of the
time because i work on
on the far right i i i've spent a lot of
time especially in recent
months talking about um black trump
supporters black members of the proud
boys
and i was recently told by a researcher
working on this
that um the key to you know the you know
there's a high bar for black members of
pro for the proud boys or these far
right organizations
but uh you know they really have to be
very christian and anti-jewish
so so uh so there there is
a route to this white supremacist
structure
that we are seeing um this white
supremacist structure that we are seeing
is uh is uh is has a route
to include non-whites but it's via
christianity
um so um so
what i think we're seeing is we're
seeing a rise and
we're not seeing ex we're seeing a rise
in
an everything but level of anti-semitism
in the united states um
there's no it's not possible to decouple
the idea of of well
let me just say that in the united
states there's a long-standing
desire of any group that is not black to
align themselves with whiteness and
and uh and jews are many american jews
are of course white uh some are black
but
some but many of many of us are white uh
and there's a desire to be on the
other side of the this traditional
division this you know this racial
hierarchy in the united states
but i think what we can see in this
growing anti-semitism
uh that gets associated with uh that
that happens
when you have these regular um protests
against
the massive racial injustice in the
country
that it comes around to jewish people to
direct that jewish people
there's no escaping that there's an
understandable desire
not to be in the target of this but the
structure of anti-semitism
uh the structure of 20th century
anti-anti-semitic conspiracy theories as
opposed say to blood libel
is that jewish people are behind
movements for equality jewish people are
behind
uh racial div you jewish people are
behind racial division
what that means is that uh
unless we deal with the fundamental
uh the fundamental causes of
racial division the massive economic
inequality
the incredible problems uh of
uh in our in our cultural system in our
prison system
um there's always going to be
uh there's always going to be as as my
colleague elizabeth hinton
is arguing in a forthcoming book
essentially revolutions
against militarized police forces
that seek to uh that that essentially
seek to
to cement and protect uh a hierarchy of
racial wealth
uh and those will then be those
revolutions
uprisings against that will be
represented
uh as the as the kind of um
as uh as we've seen as sort of threats
to law and order uh
cities out of control and given
how deeply embedded the anti-semitic
narratives are uh jewish people are
going to be implicated in that
uh and so uh you know this is a
pragmatic argument to be involved in
struggles for racial justice
uh we should there's there's clearly an
ethical and a political
there's a clearly an ethical demand that
i believe is part of my
uh my heritage here but the idea that
you could disassociate these things
um it seems seems as a scholar of
propaganda who studies
how narratives embed and are familiar to
people
they you know you can't just get rid of
a narrative and this is what we're
seeing with q anon
narratives stories they live in people's
minds they seem familiar
when they hear there's a global plot of
elites you know
you can say okay this time the jews
aren't involved this time it's another
global plot of elites
but that is an anti-semitic conspiracy
theory
the idea that you can just take out like
the original target of the conspiracy
theory
is ludicrous i mean it's implausible
let's say
there's an understandable desire to do
that but we are
america i'm saying we i i'm jewish but
american jew
i think what we're seeing the global the
the this use of anti-semitism
along with white essentially white
supremacy is sort of responses to racial
justice movements
is i think inevitable given the
structure of
uh anti-semitic conspiracy theories in
the 20th century
which link jews to movements for
equality um and uh
now uh uh so
uh uh yeah and uh and i think i'll
uh end there and take questions
okay thank you jason there are a lot of
questions and i
encourage people to um
to keep uh submitting them as as we ask
so
um start with um a factual
question here so there are a few people
want to hear more about
that video um so where uh
who made it where exactly was it shown
was it only shown
at the um january 6 rally tell us give
us a little bit more background it's
been shown at multiple
stop the steel rallies i hate even
saying the expression stop this deal
because linguistically
stop the steal presupposes that the
election was stolen
and the election was not stolen as i
have to say
and so when you say stop the steel rally
you are actually reinforcing the
propaganda
the propagandistic prank but it was
shown the december 12th stopped the
steel rally
was shown in one other uh uh was shown
in atlanta stop the steel rally was
shown at
multiple stop the steel rallies and uh
and it's of different
lengths uh and and who made it do you do
you know who
who no one's thinking it's something
called uh
the uh the right the right side
broadcasting network
they seem to have a large following on
twitter but they're very mysterious and
multiple news organizations have been
trying to figure out who is implicated
i mean i would argue i mean you know
the idea that it's not anti-static is
absolutely no no and also i would say
that it's not
a unique um you know uh example
of this i mean we saw this you know
going back to
um the 2016 election where you know
there was all kinds of
imagery that would juxtapose um
hillary with like a jewish star behind
her or
trump tweeted an image of hillary with a
uh jewish star behind her on a pile of
money
yeah exactly or things that would you
know uh single out
soros blank fine you know and
the the closing ad for the uh for trump
uh was anti-semite not as explicit as
this but
uh but it showed but it showed soros
trump
uh it showed soros blankfein and janet
yellen who's jewish
right and it was all about elites money
um yeah so so this is this is um
and of course trump has several times
called
in front of jewish american audiences
said that netanyahu is your
prime minister which is so so
a question about um something you
alluded to
which is this split on the right
um that you have some who are just pure
haters of jews and then you have some
who make an exception for israel
which i think you um you know
you know describe as as um separate but
equal but this idea it's basically this
idea that
um they in fact you know have a lot to
admire
about um israel and especially they
admire those aspects of
israel that people jews on the left have
a hard time with which is the
ethno-nationalist
you know elements but this idea that so
are you saying that what they like about
it is like
okay fine there's this state for jews
and jews should go there
is that their idea that they think that
jews don't actually belong in america
so there's multiple views uh so uh
so uh brandon tarrant the new zealand
uh uh mosque killer mass murderer um
said uh you know jews are fine as long
as they're in israel
uh so there's that's that that's one
view uh
on on the extreme right um the
uh the uh
the ethnonationalism unfortunately and
this is
really problematic has been a model for
so i was at
in giving a lecture in berlin and i went
to a rally for the off day which is
anti-semitic and the vast majority
of and i met with a german minister uh
of anti-semitism they have a special
minister and he confirmed this the vast
majority of anti-semitic
incidents in germany are done by the
right wing um so
um but they they uh but at this off day
rally alternative for deutschland the
far right
german party that one of whose main
things is to roll back holocaust
education
all the discussion we're having here
about uh
1619 project they're having in germany
about holocaust education
so uh so after runs on taking down the
monuments
in berlin the hookah uh argued that one
should take down the monuments
uh uh you know the the uh peter
eisenmann's monument to the murder jews
of europe
uh they're running on changing holocaust
education in the schools like
uh the um so uh why should we be
ashamed of our past et cetera et cetera
same exact thing is here
um uh and and they fly and the off day
rally there were many many israeli flags
being flown
so so israel's being touted as an
example
um rather than a secular liberal
democracy with jewish holidays
and a jewish history it's being touted
as an example of
of ethno-nationalism and uh and of
course
our prominent far right you know you
know uh
far-right leaders that who are linked to
netanyahu
so what about uh you know someone asked
and i can't not ask
uh you to comment on the jewish space
lasers
the uh marjorie taylor green uh where
did that come from
what what how do we eat so
so there's a couple um so q anon
as now there's a great just security
argue
article there's a terrific piece by
talia levin and uh i think it's in the
new republic
i strongly recommend talia lovin's piece
uh
david livingstone smith the brilliant
philosopher who works on dehumanization
he has a terrific piece in the foreword
on q and on all
explaining q anon well as you know
the the mother of all anti-semitic
conspiracy theories
um it marries the protocols of the
elders of zion
with blood libel so of course as we know
uh
there's multiple forms of anti-semitism
uh
uh in eastern europe western protocols
are the protocols yellow design it
originates in in russia and saint
petersburg of course but
uh it um it's really to me is associated
with it's sort of a 20th century
western european anti-semitic conspiracy
theory
um and uh and in eastern europe and the
motivates the pogroms well i don't have
to tell you maury
uh is uh is uh blood libel that jews
have these satanic rituals
q anon marries uh protocols of the
elders of zion and blood libel it
marries
the two most vicious anti-semitic
conspiracy theories
um which are different uh the protocols
the other design does not talk about
satanic rituals uh so it's remarkable to
see
a global cabal of elites who have
satanic rituals
and are trying to bring about world
communism via capitalism somehow
um so the jewish space laser thing well
that's
you know she says the rothschilds
control it right
it doesn't get older than that i mean
that's it that's just exactly
what that's what we are facing um and
what i'm saying is like
it is inextricably tied to uh
to jewish involvement in black protests
this idea
and so you know uh and you're not gonna
be able to get rid and once there's this
structure you're not going to be able to
get rid of it
yeah and so could you say a little bit
more about the relationship between
christian nationalism and white
nationalism
in the u.s are they the same and if you
could write some people want if you
could recommend something to read on
that you've been so great about
citing other people and it would be
great if you could um yeah so so
uh the perry and whitehead book uh
samuel perry and andrew whitehead's book
on american christian nationalism and
philip gorski's work uh my colleague
philip gorski here
uh they're uh both great uh kathleen
bellew
on white supremacism b-e-l-e-u a-e-w
um uh these are some recent
important works on the u.s context um
i think uh these these intersect
uh you know if you look back at um so
fascism is not
you know when you look at nazism
national socialism which i think
is the sort of that is ideologically
that is the overlap with the ku klux
klan
the ku klux klan is a white supremacist
christian nationalist
movement but you know google's in a 1935
speech communism with its mask off
says you know the judeo bolsheviks are
coming for you and they're going to
destroy traditional religion
uh the nazis are the supporters
of christianity the defenders of
traditional christianity
um so you have this conceptual
distinction between people who are
you know were the defenders of christian
nationalism from judeo-bolsheviks
and um and uh
and the uh and sort of christian
nationalism itself
uh but i think to understand uh the move
that the republican that not the
republicans because there are many
good republicans who are involved in
this at all uh but
within the republican party i believe
it's fair to say it's been allowed to
fester
um and it's growing um so uh
so you have uh an appeal for
a multi-racial and islamophobic
anti-semitic christian nationalist
movement
that will draw uh people
some people of color um and and uh
and and that will be you know uh
that i mean i i don't think we should
excessively focus on the proud boys i
was speaking to a researcher the other
day
who was working on these on militias
people need to understand that militia
movements
are embedded everywhere like michigan of
course has long had this
but all across the south as sort of
government has shrunk back
we have you know white militias
extremely low information voters these
are not the proud boys they regard the
proud boys as like
hollywood militias like that that's um
and and christianity christian
nationalism
you know there's the you know the black
people in the cities are coming for us
there's a rural urban divide um and are
there christian groups in the us that
are critical
of that uh of the christian
ethno-nationalism
oh yeah especially black christian
groups
yeah but uh but uh yeah i mean
christianity is
uh you know uh uh i mean
uh is a very wide tent so i don't think
by any means
uh you know uh you know you had
you had a kind of good fortune as a this
is discussed in
in bradley hart's book on uh hitler's
american friends
uh you had a kind of good fortune that
father coughlin was catholic
he was deeply anti-semitic but he wasn't
embraced by
pro all the protestants because he was
catholic
so uh so you know the there's different
there's a history of anti-catholicism in
the united states among
these uh movements but i think actually
that's ending and we're finding a far
right christian nationalist integralist
quasi-fascist movement among the
catholics in the united states
and what about um so you know there are
a couple questions
about people saying where do you see the
greater threat
to jews in america especially or maybe
than you know to the world
do you see it coming more from the right
these right-wing groups that you're
talking about or what about
you know um is islamist anti-semitism
or you know as some people say you know
anti-semitism on the left
and on college campuses and things like
that how do you
parse well i don't think i think i think
that um
you know there's fundamentalist
religions and islam has fundamentalism
judaism has fundamentalism
christianity has fundamentalism um those
are all from the right
um uh you know islamic fundamentalism is
a right wing and there's no such thing
as left-wing anti-feminism
anti-gay you know uh so so
you know i mean there's anti-colonial
movements there's people who are
uh but uh but i don't think there's
there's you know
we when people say when people say louis
farrakhan is left-wing i have to laugh
i mean louis farrakhan is a homophobic
anti-feminist
uh trump-supporting uh uh
right-wing ultra-nationalist now he
happens to be an ultra-nationalist
for for so my book i discuss black
nationalism
and you know kind the version of zionism
that not my version that is
ethnonationalist in our uh character
that that uh you know those originate as
movements that are minority nationalist
movements
uh minority nationalist but you know
fanon is very good on this on violence
he says
if a minority a nationalist movement can
start as an anti-colonialist movement
but once it takes over the country and
wins
it has to stop that it has to become
more inclusive it has to become
you know so fanon really well describes
it uh you know farrak but you have these
you know black nationalism there are
extremely patriarchal conservative
right-wing elements there
islamophobia um so i think
i think uh i mean so islam islamic you
know
there's obviously fundamentalist uh
groups in every religion and islam is no
exception to that
so i think you know fundamentalism and
again
ali stern is a great scholar has done
great work here
on exploring the ways in which um
orthodox
uh orthodox jews have have
engaged in anti-semitism against liberal
jews
and secular jews yes let's talk a little
bit
um more about that so there are a couple
questions about
um you know jewish uh
you know right-wing jews and what to
make of the fact
that um you know ultra-orthodox or her
ready jews
did support trump and and what how do
you
explain that are they um
you know do they not care about um the
anti-semitic elements that you've been
showing that are
you know at the heart of you know if not
trump himself necessarily but trumpism
what what do you how do you explain that
yeah and and
the orthodox there's orthodox
communities in hungary who support
victor obama
um so uh so again at least
i mean here i just rely on professor
stern's work
who is the scholar of this in the world
right now um
he's investigating the deep history of
the orthodoxy
it's turned to the right um
so uh one aspect you find in in
stern scholarship is uh is
uh for is sort of first a description
stern breaks down and i've seen some of
the manuscript of his forthcoming book
breaks down the ways in with ortox
judaism in the united states
looks like uh fundamentalist
christianity or fundamentalist
islam private schools they want private
schools
paid for by the government um guns the
israel you know um herzl partly wanted
this about israel to change the image of
jews from
pete you know uh from from a sort of one
kind of
uh you know from me or whatever to uh
and you to
to sort of soldiers with guns and and so
that sort of gun culture
has exists um so uh among
is no it's not you know the nra is not
an institution that is autom
automatically seems anathema uh if
you're if you're used to various tropes
um from israel uh and uh stern talks
about how
we need to pay attention to the fact
that many jewish people
might not themselves be orthodox but yet
they're
they're they're part of an orthodox
community
uh of values and and so so
there are many common interests between
fundamentalist religious groups i mean
it was a great it's really a mystery to
me
that that the republican party has not
appealed to
uh to uh muslim americans
incredibly wealthy prosperous successful
group many which does have you know
group sub groups that that would be
naturally republican
like orthodox jews it should be no
surprise that fundamentalists grouped
that very religious groups not from very
religious groups
um have common interests and what we see
is that
right and that um you know i think does
explain some of the what
took a lot of people by surprise which
was um you know
a certain latino vote for trump you know
which um you know shocked people but you
know that for
you know conservative catholics and
there is actually a question about which
is not exactly the same thing
but about the intersection between
right wing catholicism like extreme
you know that kind of extreme brand that
um steve bannon
and michael flynn have been part you
know and um
q anon and this phenomenon that you're
talking about
um before i want to say one more thing
about anti-semitism
about right with about anti-semitism
even among jews uh
i was told recently that the it's it's
ashkenazi jews who
who often get subject to this okay so a
question about
um what to say to people who say
um well trumpism can't be
fundamentally there can't be
anti-semitism in it because look
you know trump's own grandchildren are
jewish you know you've got
you know jared and ivanka are orthodox
jews how do you respond
to that um
i mean i think again it helps to think
about
race here where many uh
i mean i'm not i'm not talking about
what is in trump's heart
trump himself says many things that are
you know
uh i want jews counting my money or you
know
you know uh speaking to jewish audiences
talking about greed and
uh so uh i mean i think that uh
the fact is that you can have uh you can
be a white person
married into with black with a black
grandchild and still
be uh be uh be racist
the i'm not saying trump is anti-semitic
uh but i'm saying the fact that he has
a jewish um uh jewish
uh son-in-law um who repeatedly is
referred to as the globalist member of
the
cabinet uh does not does not mean that
he's not using anti-semitic policies i
mean you
politics engage in anti-semitic politics
i think there's no question
we're seeing anti-semitic politics and
tactics being used
let's stop asking what's in people's
hearts and
start asking what they're doing what
they're doing to retain power
anti-semitism is always
and will always be a powerful way to
grab power in a country um
you know spreading conspiracy theories
where you know my my theory of my
of anti-semitism i lean toward a theory
that says uh young philosopher and
joshua stein is working this out that
jews are the center of you know any
conspiracy theory like they're the group
that is aimed at
um and i think that that kind of if we
think of
fascism as i do in my work as a set of
tactics
to retain power we realize like somebody
like an israeli politician can use those
tactics
um it was a terrific article in the
intercept years ago which is
now uh scrubbed away um
called how steve bannon made breitbart
into a pro-israel uh haven for
anti-summons
i got in the comments it was all
anti-semites and and
and it talked about how in israel there
was lots and lots of anti-semitic
propaganda aimed at left
labor politicians um very explicit
anti-semitic propaganda
because who knows anti-semit
anti-semitic propaganda and how to use
it
better than you know i mean better than
you know i was raised being told about
it by my parents
okay so there are a lot of questions and
i first of all let me apologize
because i'm not gonna be able to get to
all of these questions there's so many
questions
um which is really a sign of how engaged
this audience is which is great
but there are a lot of questions about
they basically boil down to
what can we do about this um what
what kind of practical or even
philosophical
you know resistance can we offer to
um the situation that you're outlining
here
i i think that anti-semitism racism
these ills uh rise in
but especially anti-semitism uh
rises in conditions where people feel
the government has betrayed them
where the government is really in
control
by some elites who are benefiting and i
think the number one thing we can do
to stem anti-semitism is a massive
program
to make government work again in the
face of covet
um you will never eliminate
anti-semitism as an ill that is
i think i think tragically permanent but
uh uh but uh wait we're echoing we're
not going
um do you hear back up do you hear that
no no
so uh so so but i think that in moments
of enormous
anxiety economic enormous anxiety
fear the feel you're feeling that your
government
has deeply betrayed you this tends to
lead to
uh increase in anti-semitism
blaming certain groups with the jews so
if there's this
the elite have betrayed us they've
betrayed us they're funneling our money
they're dividing us they're betraying us
so you know if we if we can address
the uh racial division in our country if
we can if we can address a racial
injustice
and tamp down the sort of supposedly
outward
signs of of of the what the jews are
doing
uh by uh addressing racial inequality
and the horrific conditions facing many
black americans
and then direct large show that the
government is working for all americans
rural urban
uh in the face of covid then you will
cut down
the base you'll do problem dissolution
very interesting and one you know thing
people have pointed out that and i want
to give you the chance to you know to
say this that um
you know you're not saying that all uh
you know orthodox jews
are racist or anything like that you
know so just you know and in fact there
are many
you know yeah no orthodontics
absolutely not or involved in any sense
in in racism i'm saying they too will be
we all orthodox and non-orthodox jews
will be targets of
of a growing white supremacist movement
uh
of course uh i don't think orthodox
uh you know what what i was talking i
i'm you know and i'm not even
um yeah i don't think i don't think when
orthodox jews
vote for trump they're voting uh i mean
there's a racism problem among
all white communities let's be let's
face it i mean
all white communities in america have a
racism problem
you know so you know i don't want to
exonerate either and it's not orthodox
and non-orthodox there are plenty of
there are plenty of people who deny that
racism
despite vast evidence that are of
massive
racial inequality at birth uh uh
racial wealth gaps enormous racial
wealth gaps
10 10 to 20 to 1. um all white
communities are
implicated but i don't see orthodox jews
or non-orthodox jews
any more implicat you know and are black
orthodox jews
that i know that are from and you know
so
uh and but i don't see orthodox
communities
uh implicated in racism any more than
any other group that is
majority white but if but let's face it
if you want the government to pay for
private schools for your people and
that's your primary interest
you are implicated in racism in the
united states because
we need the government we need funds to
go
to uh people who don't have
who have been historically unjustly
oppressed
uh and subjugated and so if you're in
any community be it
a white christian community an islamic
community
a hindu community a jewish community
that is pushing for certain policies
that are going to have downstream
negative effects
like um paying for schools just for your
own
group rather than addressing
inequalities you're going to be
implicated
okay and last question because we're
almost out of time but do you
feel that um the fact that the trump
administration is behind us that we're
now starting
you know the biden administration is
that a cause
for hope i mean in the sense that um
these uh uh anti-some you know
anti-semitism and and um all this
rhetoric might
dissipate a little bit or do you see it
as you know
is the the rage and stop the steel anger
going to actually make it worse
i think that anti-semitism is an ill
that is permanent in american society in
many societies laid dormant this is a
country in which we have been
flourished like almost no other country
uh but it's like
playing with fire and and so it's out
now it's out in very open ways that have
never been this open
uh in my lifetime and uh and
it it threatens uh and it's ju and it's
gonna be the basis
and we have many q and on supporters
openly in congress
and i've never seen anything like it and
we had the conditions and we have like
15 months to deal with the social basis
of mistrust that we know from history
uh feeds anti-semitic anti-semitism
in far right ethno-nationalist movements
so no it's it's i feel it it could it
could be the calm before the storm
yeah okay well on that note um please
join me everyone in silently thanking
professor jason stanley for what was
really a very
um stimulating and um fascinating talk
so thank you jason
for doing this and especially on such
short notice and
um yes thank you so thank you so much